Detroit developed best whether it was
bottom-up when small communities small
parishes small schools reform that's
when Detroit prospered
my name is Harry Verizon and I grew up
in Detroit I teach at the University of
Detroit Mercy I have just written the
book called you didn't have to be this
way which is a critique of the
interventionist system which is I think
caused an awful lot of this trouble it
was a very vibrant city when I was a kid
and it was really the glory days of
Detroit it was the glory days of the
automobile and Detroit really grew up as
a collection of communities and I would
stress this government doesn't create
community the government's part of
community but communities much wider and
Detroit was ideally located because in
the North you had all the iron ore and
in the south you had all the coal and
was all connected by water so it was a
very very inexpensive place to build
things so by 1951 Detroit had the
highest standard of living in the world
it had 1.8 million people because
remember one of the things that makes a
city grow is cost in those days you
didn't have an income tax
you didn't have an inheritance tax I
mean Henry Ford started a little bicycle
shop all the money he made was plugged
back in the Ford Motor Company so that's
what built Ford Motor Company as well as
a lot of other companies today that
would be very difficult to do because
it's very difficult to hold on to those
profits and you have to go to outside
financing about to witness the very
exciting story of a city and its people
I really marked the fall in 1961 with
the election of Jerome P Cavanaugh
Cavanaugh brought in to Detroit City
income tax and the sewage had the city
income tax immediately you had pressure
from companies to move out Triple A was
the first one to move out across 8 Mile
Road and all they had to do is move 8
miles out to 8 Mile Road their Telegraph
Road and there's no income tax so
suddenly now it became more costly to
live in Detroit we have the highest
taxes in the state
Detroit is a very caustic place to live
as we in sense zone Detroit that we made
these pockets we created areas where
crime could flourish to have a
neighborhood of just factories or
neighborhood of just stores or
neighborhoods and just houses invites
crime but when you have a mixed
neighborhood when you
manufacturing retail families schools
all mixed together the neighborhood has
eyes and it keeps crime down and of
course is crime flourished and it was
more expensive and we continued to
increase taxes and increase taxes people
moved out it was really the dream of
progressivism the idea that things can
be planned from the top
Detroit developed best whether it was
bottom-up when small communities small
parishes small schools reform that's
when Detroit prospered and the more
centralization you got and the more
pulling things up to the top the worse
it got by the church by the union's by
the city government by the federal
government completely wrecked the small
communities here for example the hot
house scandal George Romney the governor
Michigan the very progressive Republican
governor he was a planner and he thought
he could plan the place and so the idea
was as will use welfare payments as
income streams to pay off mortgages a
lot of people did what they would do is
they would buy these houses because the
federal government was guaranteeing the
mortgage so the banks didn't worry they
were glad to finance it and the people
then would move in not having any
respect for property would stripped the
houses of anything valuable and they
move on to the next house and there were
blocks and blocks of Detroit that were
destroyed in the later 60s and early 70s
it was called the HUD house scandal it's
going to be very hard to get rid of
progressivism this concept that bigger
is better and that that uniformity and
whatever else is better and I think now
Detroit offers a perfect example to the
country of where this country will head
if this trend towards progressivism
continues
what could turn it around for Detroit I
think is maybe the hope that the
bankruptcy will clean a lot of this out
if for example the bankruptcy can can
end a lot of these very expensive
programs allow the neighborhoods to
redevelop that may help the first thing
I would do is break the City Council
units into very small units maybe ten
blocks each so that you no longer have
to rely on big contributions and big
labor to get elected the other thing I
think as I dumped the zoning laws I
think the sooner we get rid of those the
better it would be now we're not going
to get the large industrial plants
because that's gone by the boards
I mean manufacturing today is not done
with 10,000 people in the plant it's
done very small diversified industries a
city survives on a wide group of Ages
you have to have young couples having
children who will send their kids to
schools that are safe and academically
excellent you have to have parents
obviously and middle-aged folks you have
to have old folks because they're due
eyes of the neighborhood and we have to
realize that the community has to
develop itself it's organic it's not
going to come back with government
planning it's going to come back when
government gets out of the way and
allows the decisions to be made at the
local level again